This video was made possible by Hover.
Buy your custom domain and email before it’s
gone for 10% off at hover.com/wendover.
The United States, despite its geopolitical
prominence, is flanked by but two countries.
To the north, the 5,525 mile, 8,891 kilometer
line separating it from Canada represents
the longest border in the world.
To the south, the 1,954 mile, 3,145 kilometer
US-Mexico border is perhaps one of the most
significant in the world.
It separates two of the most economically
and socially interlinked countries in the
world.
The US buys more from Mexico than any other
country, Mexico buys more from the US than
any other country, and Mexico sells more to
the US than any other country.
Beyond that, there are some 37 million people
living in the US with Mexican ancestry, which
is a truly staggering statistic.
That means there are more Mexicans living
in the US than there are people living in
Canada, full stop.
Both the US and Mexico rely hugely on this
continuous flow of people and money back and
forth, which means how well this border functions
is directly tied to the success of both countries.
Unfortunately for both, though, this border,
while significant, has its issues.
A border and its effectiveness involves far
more than the line itself—it’s about how
well the overall immigration system between
the two countries functions—but, at the
end of the day, that line is still quite important.
The Mexico-US border is crossed more than
any other restricted border in the world,
meaning it’s actually quite porous.
There are fifty spots where one can legally
cross the border by land.
The smallest is the tiny Boquillas Port of
Entry in Big Bend National Park where about
11,000 annual travelers are processed remotely
using video inspection kiosks—mostly to
make day-trips to the small Mexican town of
Boquillas del Carmen while vacationing in
the National Park.
On the other hand, the largest crossing is
the San Ysidro Port of Entry, processing 11
million pedestrians and 26 million cars per
year—thereby making it the busiest land
border checkpoint in the western hemisphere.
As part of the primary route between San Diego
and Tijuana—two cities between which people
commute on a daily basis—this crossing is
never not busy.
The rest of this 1,954 mile, 3,145 kilometer
line, beyond these 50 checkpoints, is secured
as, to go from Mexico to the US, or the US
to Mexico, you have to go through immigration
checkpoints—at least to do it legally.
Each and every year, hundreds of thousands
or millions of people attempt to cross into
the US, via the southern border, without the
legal right to do so.
In short, they try to migrate illegally.
Now, the vast majority of these undocumented
immigrants are not successful in their endeavor—an
estimated 55 to 85 percent of them are caught
and sent back to their home country—but
to many people, these odds are worth it.
There is enormous economic disparity between
the US, where average income is at $65,000
per year, and Mexico, where that number stands
at $9,500 per year.
Also, while low compared to other wealthy
countries, the US scores much better than
Mexico on social mobility meaning a poor person
is more likely to become wealthier in their
lifetime in the US than Mexico.
In short, while there are certainly nearly
infinite reasons why someone might choose
to migrate to the US—including, quite often,
family reunification or an escape from violence—research
has shown that money, and the attempt to escape
poverty, is typically the strongest and primary
one.
Of course, the question is, why don’t these
people migrate to the US legally?
It would certainly be safer and cheaper.
Well, overwhelmingly the answer is because
they can’t.
For some people, there is no legitimate route
to legal status in the US, and, to others,
there’s no practical way.
Many forms of American immigrant visas have
annual caps that are not proportional to immigration
demand from a given country.
That means that, for example, if you were
a married, Mexican-citizen who was the son
or daughter of a US citizen, the wait time
to have your visa processed currently stands
at twenty-four years.
That means that now, in September 2020, they’re
currently only processing applications submitted
up until August 1st, 1996.
Faced with the prospect of waiting 24 years,
more than a fourth of their life, until they
can live and work in the same country as their
parents or, for example, take care of them
in old age, many people seeking this and other
classes of visas choose not to wait, and rather
take the faster, yet riskier option of immigrating
without authorization.
While dangerous, the process of crossing the
border illegally is a path generally not taken
alone.
Back twenty years ago, people had to figure
out this process themselves, but nowadays,
upwards of 95% of first time crossers hire
a smuggler to help them.
That’s an expensive proposition, with the
average fee hovering around $3,500 per person—about
four month’s wages for the average Mexican.
In exchange for their fees, these smugglers
will generally group migrants together, transport
them to the border, give them instructions
on how to cross, and then arrange for transportation
on the other side.
The migrants and smugglers really have two
choices in terms of which obstacle to face—the
border security itself, or nature.
There is never no security, but in many places
there is minimal as hundreds of miles of empty,
dry, desert plains lay between the border
and the nearest city, where migrants can disappear
into the crowd.
This sheer isolation is a big reason why there
is no physical man-made barrier on the border
in almost all of Texas, and across many other
stretches in New Mexico, Arizona, and California.
It's tough to get an exact figure, as it’s
ever changing and poorly recorded, but currently,
only about a third of the border is secured
with a barrier.
In fact, the majority of that third takes
the form of a vehicle barrier, intended only
to stop a car or truck from driving across
the border, rather than a full pedestrian
barrier.
Generally there’s only a pedestrian barrier
in heavily populated areas like Brownsville,
El Paso, Yuma, and San Diego.
Even in these populated areas, one doesn't
have to go far to find a gap in the wall.
Starting from the western end of the border
at the Pacific Ocean, the first wall-less
section appears less than 15 miles or 23 kilometers
to the east, at the first section of steep
terrain.
Any barrier, though, doesn’t tend to be
too much of an issue for smugglers.
Often, they’ll have scouts on both sides,
wait for border patrol to leave the area,
then install a ladder and quickly climb over.
Cartels have been known to go even a step
further and build tunnels under the border.
In January, 2020, US Customs and Border Protection
discovered the longest ever—a 4,300 foot,
1,300 meter structure stretching from Tijuana
to San Diego.
This facility was so advanced that it had
ventilation, electricity, a rail system, and
even an elevator.
While its unclear exactly who built and operated
this tunnel, in the past, many of these have
been linked to large crime syndicates like
the Sinaloa Cartel, demonstrating the unintended
consequences that securing the border can
have.
Demand for hard drugs is fairly inelastic,
meaning people who consume them are going
to buy them no matter the cost.
As it gets harder and harder for drugs and
other controlled substances to be smuggled
across, the cartels are still going to transport
their product, but they’re just going to
use more advanced tactics.
These tactics are going to be too costly or
difficult for smaller smugglers, but the cartels,
with their vast resources, will be able to
build tunnels, use drones, or use other tactics,
and, with their smaller competition unable
to transport goods, they’re also going to
be able to raise prices.
Therefore, there’s a possibility that making
smuggling harder is helping the largest cartels
make more money.
A related effect happens with the human side
of smuggling.
Naturally, the sections of the border that
are most secured are those that are easiest
to cross—those near population centers,
roads, and areas with less treacherous terrain.
That means that, as the border is secured,
that pushes migrants to more and more remote
areas, where the chances of injury or death
are higher and higher.
One of the more common places for migrants
to now cross into the US is the Sonoran Desert.
This area is incredibly desolate and harsh,
with high temperatures in the summer rarely
dipping below 100 degrees Fahrenheit or 38
degrees Celsius, and winter nighttime lows
dipping below freezing.
The most accessible section, next to a Mexican
Federal Highway, has a pedestrian fence preventing
crossing.
As these data show, this is effective at pushing
migrants further to the east.
After getting dropped off near the border
on the Mexican side, migrants will fairly
immediately cross the border, which is usually
one of the easiest components of their trips.
The closest roads in the US to the border
in this area are Highways 85 and 86, but,
as there are so few roads here, these are
major chokepoints where migrants could be
caught.
In addition, US Customs and Border Protection
have internal checkpoints, where they question
drivers and, potentially, pull them aside
for search to determine if anyone is undocumented
or smuggling illegal substances.
Therefore, at the very least, migrants need
to walk twenty to thirty miles to Highway
86 in order to avoid the internal checkpoint.
Many might go further, all the way to Interstate
8, with the end goal of making it to Phoenix
or Tucson.
As soon as a migrant gets to one of these
spots, it is far easier to blend into the
crowd as both cities have large immigrant
populations.
From there, they’ll be able to catch public
transportation to their final destination.
Many, however, don’t make it that far—and
not because they are caught by border patrol.
This map, showed earlier, displays the site
of every confirmed migrant death in Arizona.
The true number, as these only represent those
that are found, is likely devastatingly higher.
Every year, many hundreds of individuals die
on their journey to a better life.
In response to the staggering death toll in
this area, different groups have initiated
efforts to help those that are dehydrated,
hypothermic, or otherwise injured.
The US Customs and Border Protection Agency
itself built a system of alert beacons in
this desert that those in distress can activate.
In response, agents are supposed to arrive
and help the individual, but, of course, in
the end, they will be deported if they lack
legal status.
Other, non-governmental groups have also initiated
efforts.
One of the major causes of death is dehydration,
with there being essentially no natural water
source in this area, so humanitarian groups
have set up water stations at spots in the
desert that migrants can use if they’re
in a dire situation.
Of course, both of these interventions are
controversial—humanitarian groups say that
the beacons are tricking migrants into getting
themselves arrested since there’s no clear
indication that it’s border patrol that
will arrive and ultimately arrest them, rather
than an ambulance or a humanitarian group,
while the border patrol says that the water
stations push migrants to further continue
their dangerous journey where they might perish
due to another situation, such a hypothermia,
therefore putting them at further risk.
At the end of the day, though, both of these
interventions deal with the downstream effect
of illegal immigration, rather than the actual
source cause of it.
True, complete, physical border security can
work somewhat.
It certainly cannot stop illegal immigration,
but it does curb it to an extent, but it is
hugely expensive and almost certainly is not
the easiest solution.
The cause of illegal immigration is not that
the border isn’t secured, and it’s not
even that the countries that migrants come
from are impoverished or dangerous.
The cause of illegal immigration is that legal
immigration is not an option.
Nobody wants to risk their life just to move
to a new country and live in fear of deportation
for the rest of their life.
When Americans want to move to Canada, for
example, they don’t sneak across the border,
they don’t live undocumented for the rest
of their life, restraining themselves to only
certain, low-paid jobs.
They take the easier route, the legal route,
because they can.
If they are denied, it is generally due to
certain qualifications they lack, so they
go off and gain those qualifications.
Many people in Mexico, Central America, and
other less-wealthy areas, meanwhile, simply
don’t even have the option of migrating
to the US legally.
There is no reasonable, legal path like Americans
have for Canada.
Canada, a country who’s immigration system
certainly is not perfect, has essentially
halted illegal immigration, despite bordering
a country home to tens of millions of undocumented
migrants.
They certainly don’t let everyone who wants
to live there indefinitely do so, but they
at least have a reasonable, feasible path
to legal status for anyone no matter their
country of origin or economic situation.
When they can go through the safe, legal route,
there’s no good reason for people to migrate
illegally.
Building physical systems to stop illegal
immigration might make sense if it were a
physical problem, but it’s not.
People don’t cross the border outside official
channels because it’s physically possible.
That’s a pull factor, but illegal immigration
is caused by push factors.
It’s a social problem, so to solve it, and
cut it down, you need social systems, such
as a real immigration system that gives opportunities
to all, not just those that are lucky.
Your virtual identity is more important than
ever, especially as business is increasingly
conducted online.
Just as you present yourself right when working
in person by showering, shaving, and dressing
well, you want to be sure you’re presenting
yourself right online, and one of the best
ways that I use to do that is a custom domain
for my website and email.
I buy all my domains through Hover, as they
have clear, fair pricing, a super-fast search
and purchase process, and over 400 domain
extensions that make it super easy to find
a super-unique domain.
For example, all of my company’s emails
end in @wendover.productions rather than a
typical .com or .net domain.
You can make your email address or website
stand out by doing this too, and it’s worth
doing now because every day, more and more
domains are taken.
Hover’s pricing is so fair that whenever
I have an idea for something new, the first
thing I do is buy the corresponding domain
to be sure it’s not taken by someone else.
Whether it’s the name of your YouTube channel,
your business, or just your actual name, buy
your domain and improve your online identity
now for 10% off by going to hover.com/wendover,
and you’ll be supporting the channel while
you’re at it.